- "Expect the arrival of
your first grandchild," what?
- [Voiceover] Oh!
- What? What?
(screaming and laughing)
We're havin' a baby!
- Look at this one. Oh!
Are you pregnant?
(all screaming)
Oh my God! Oh my God!
- (screaming and laughing)
No kidding! Are you really?
Are you really, are you really?
Oh! (laughing)
- Oh my God! Oh my God!
- What the Hell is that?
(man laughing)
Oh, I'm gonna be a grandma, man!
(screaming)
I'm gonna be a grandma!
(sobbing)
(man giggling)
- [Voiceover] That's
such a great reaction!
- (shrieking) Oh, they're
gonna have a baby!
- [Voiceover] They are?
(woman squealing)
- [Voiceover] I'm pregnant.
(screaming)
- I just pooped in my pants.
(laughing from offscreen)
(shriek)
(all screaming)
(woman laughing)
- Congratulations, oh my God!
- "World's best grandpa," oh what is it?
- [Voiceover] "My grandma is the coolest."
(woman laughing)
"I love my Aunt Katy."
(piano and violin music)